hallo leute ich bin gerade auf dem 16
arzt und
mal gucken was da so
für ein scheiß gibt
spiel zeigen
beispiel 2
ursachen erforschen
ich habe etwas gefunden
sagte
es ist ein flash maker das tut man in
die gefriertruhe also den becher soll
dann sein lieblingsgetränk terrain tun
und dann hat man ein eigenes flaschen zu
hause waren
also ich habs jetzt in die gefriertruhe
getan ist es jetzt eiskalt also ich kann
es kaum anfassen so ein getränk ist auch
gekauft
ich hab jetzt punica genommen ich hatte
keine ahnung was für ein getränk man da
vielleicht nehmen sollte von irgendwie
witzig aus dass ich will ich will nicht
sagen die so aussieht denken wie es
aussieht so dann gibt's jetzt ans
eingemachte
die julis entlädt letzte magicstar
macht mal drin steckt jetzt fluss nicht
geeignet machen wird ich bin drauf
das hat sich nicht gut angehört finden
knete einfach kneten
wir müssen das gerät nur kneten nicht
wichtig ob sich so kurzen ob ich habs
jetzt drei stunden cool aussieht wenn
man es mit cooler musik unterlegt und
sieht vielleicht besser aus
es läuft mir echt an der seite aus wo
zur hölle leute raus
habe ich überall multivitaminsaft kinder
kinder kriegen das nicht hin
ich werde auf jeden fall nochmal in die
gefriertruhe tun und wundert euch dann
nicht über den schnitt der jetzt kommt
denn das wird nach ein paar stunden
seien sie dann wahrscheinlich anders aus
oder ein bisschen müde weiterspielt sein
wird also kaum überraschung
es ist jetzt nicht abends ist der
nächste tag weil ich zu faul war es
nochmals zu drehen und das licht ist
echt schlecht gewesen also net mei
football und sonne wolke sonne wollte
also wundert euch nicht wenn das nicht
die ganze zeit wechselt ich habe jetzt
hier ein richtig schön war okay ich
glaube ich weiß warum es gestern nicht
geklappt hat wird jetzt einfach anfangen
zu kneten
ganz frech wie ich bin
und mein gott
plötzlich ganz anders als gäste und
nicht über und es gibt schon am rand um
mein gott ich bin gerade der
glücklichste mensch der welt
es kostet 14 99 glaube ich in 15 euro
wir haben jetzt die männliche kröten
löffel der löffel sogar integrierten
schwalheim
locker wenn ihr fragen an mich habt wie
an den kommentaren auf schreiben dass
ich viel leben kann mit meinen augen
gleich meister masako video so mach und
standard denken wenn nicht überhaupt
wenn ihr eine frau gehabt das war mal im
wandel
jungs ich bin raus bis denn